اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الاهم الانباء من العربيه والبدايه
بالعناوين
موريل يتحدث عن تقدم طفيف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع روسيا وكندا تعتبر موقف
الهند من الحرب رساله مهمه
قصه تؤكد للعربيه انا داعش يعد لعمليات
الانتقاميه ويخطط لعوده جديده انطلاقا من
الرقه ومخيم
حزب الخير يشق صف مائده الست التركيه بسبب
كلتشدار اوغلو والاخير يطمئن انصاره لا
تقلق
مشاهدينا الكرام نتوقف مع هذا الخبر بقلوب
مؤمنه بقضاء الله وقدره تنعى شبكه العربيه
والعربيه الحدث الزميل الاعلاميه نجوى
قاسم
وعلى مدى 20 عاما في سباق الخبر تضحيات
واصابات وفرسان ترجل ورحله العربيه مستمره
في البدايه تستمر العربيه في تغطيه العيد
العشرين مع اسماء ورموز قدموا تضحيات كي
يبقى الخبر سباقا على شاشتكم العربيه
واخرون ظلوا في سباق حتى النفس الاخير
ولكن اولا مع اهم واخر الاخبار حتى الان
في تفاصيل اكد منسق سياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل وجود تحسن
دبلوماسي طفيف مع روسيا خلال اجتماع
مجموعه العشرين في الهند حيث واثنا بوريل
على بقاء وزير الخارجيه الروسي سرجينا في
قاعه الاجتماع واستباعه اثناء دانه الدول
الغربيه للعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
ووصف ذلك بدليل مهم وبانه افضل من لا شيء
في اشاره الى الانسحاب من قمه بال العام
الماضي هذا وعرض المسؤول الاوروبي استبعاد
روسيا من مجموعه العشرين مشددا على اهميه
الاحتفاظ بسبل التواصل من جهتها اعتبرت
وزيره الخارجيه الكنديه ان التصريح الهندي
بتعطيل روسيا والصين للاجتماع رساله بحد
ذاتها وغلفت الى ابلاغها لابروف خلال لقاء
جمعها بضروره وجمعهما بضروره انسحاب روسيا
من اوكرانيا وبان ذلك نقطه على السطر وفق
تعبيرها
والمحلل السياسي
ما الحل ايضا اذا كانت روسيا لا تؤمن
بتصريحات ومواقف للسلام وفي المقابل كيف
لا تؤمن لا بالمبادره الصينيه ولا
بالمواقف الروسيه ما المخرج
المخرج هو على ساحه القتال الكل تعرف
الروسي والاوكراني لا يظل يعاون على
استمرار العمليات القتاليه في على ساحه
القتال فيعاون على ان كل تعرف يمكن ان
يتواصل الى اهداف التي تحتاج اليها فعلى
ما يبدو كل تعرف
يعتبر انه سيستطيع ان يتفرق
الاخر فلذلك
التفاوض لدبلوماسيه بين روسيا واوكرانيا
بين روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فلذلك الى اي مدى ستستمر هذه الحرب نتحدث
عن الحرب لها سنه حتى الان لم يبدي اي طرف
من الاطراف تراجعا عن مواقفه السابقه وما
زالت الغلبه لاصوات المدافع حتى الان
صحيح ولكن اولا قد تكون هناك تغيرات جزريه
على ساحه القتال هو سبيل الاول لايجاد
مخرج من هذه الازمه ثانيا قد يكون مخرج
سياسيا بسبب ليس سيرا في العام القادم
ستكون هناك الانتخابات الرئاسيه في كل من
روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الحل هذا شيء يجب ان يؤثر بشكل او باخر
على الازمه الاوكرانيه فلذلك من جيده اقول
لم يحن الوقت
لانتقال من العمل لهذا القتاليه الى الى
طور الحوار فلذلك نحن فقط بحاجه لمزيد من
الوقت طيب هل ترى بان الحل من واشنطن وليس
من هذه المره
بطبيعه الحال بسبب
لولا امريكا لا نجحت روسيا على ساحه
القتال في اوكرانيا قبل اشهر نحن نعلم
وندرك تماما من امريكا تقدم مليارات او
عشرات مليارات دولار من المصادات العسكريه
والماليه واخيرا من مصادرات لاوكرانيا
فهذا فقط يسمح لاوكرانيا ان تستمر في
اجراء العمليه القتاليه باضافه الى
التدريب لتصليح وغيرها من المصادات فلذلك
جزء من القرار على الاقل هو في واشنطن في
حال فعلا لانهاء
[موسيقى]
التواصل مع المحلل السياسيه
اكد مؤسس قوات الروسيه ان مدينه محمود
باتت تحت الحصار الكامل عمليا
الى امتلاك القوات الاوكرانيه الطريقه او
لطريق خروج واحد من المدينه داعيا الرئيس
الاوكراني
سبعه اشهر من القتال الدموي في بخمه
الاوكرانيه تتجه نحو الحسم لصالح روسيا في
الايام الاخيره تعرض طريق الامداد الوحيد
لقصف روسي كثيف لتزيد صعوبه الحصار على
المدينه
قوات فاجنر الروسيه التي تقاتل في المدينه
منذ اشهر اعلنت عن حصار المدينه تماما بعد
التقدم الذي احرزته في الاسابيع الاخيره
شمال وجنوبي المدينه طريق وحيد هو الذي
بقي منفذا باتجاه الغرب مؤديا الى مدينه
تشاسيفيار
رساله جاءت على لسان مؤسسها الذي خطب
الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي مطالبا
اياه باستغلال الوقت واخراج من تبقى من
المدينه ابراج
حاصرت وحدات فاجنر عمليا مدينه ولم يتبقى
منها سوى طريق واحد اذا كنا نقاتل في وقت
سابق ضد الجيش المحترف فاننا نرى الان
بشكل متزايد كبار السن والاطفال انهم
يقاتلون لكن الوقت المتوقع في بخموت قصير
جدا لا يتجاوز يوما او يومين لمنحهم فرصه
لمغادره المدينه
كل من طرفي الصراع الدموي في ضخمه يدعيانه
الحق خسائر فادحه بالطرف الاخر انهم لا
ياخذون في الحسبان خسائرهم في محاوله
الاستيلاء على المدينه بالهجوم تتمثل مهمه
قواتنا في بخمط في الحاق اكبر عدد ممكن من
الخسائر بالعدو
القوات المدافعه عن المدينه تصر على
الصمود في الدفاع معترفه بصعوبه الوضع في
الميدان بالتزامن مع سحب بعض الوحدات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه من مناطق سيطرتك
معركه باخموتيلا باتت تجسد الصمود
الاوكراني تتجه نحو الحسم الا ان القتال
المستميت وسقوطها في يد القوات الروسيه لن
يكون تقدما استراتيجيا حقيقيا لروسيا بحسب
المحللين اذا عمر العربيه
عبر السفير الاوكراني لدى المانيا عن
سعادته بقرارات المستشار الالماني خلال
شهور الاخيره وثمن التزامها برلين بدعم
كيف حتى النصر في المواجهه مع روسيا
انا سعيد بما قاله المستشار الالماني وما
فعلته الحكومه الالمانيه في الاشهر
الاخيره وسعيد جدا ايضا بتضامن جميع
الاحزاب الديمقراطيه خلال مناظره اليوم
لقد تاكدنا من دعم المانيا لنا حتى نحقق
الانتصار في الحرب
وصفات الخارجيه صينيه الولايات المتحده
بانها اكبر مصدر للتهديد النووي عالميا
كما طالبتها بان تعيد التفكير بدقه في
سياستها النوويه والوفاء بمسؤولياتها
الخاصه والاساسيه بشان نزع السلاح وان
تقلل من دور الاسلحه النوويه في سياسه
الامن القومي
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه كادت قائدته
وحدات حمايه المراه في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه نوروز احمد ان تنظيم داعش يعد
لمزيد من العمليات الانتقاميه واوضحت
تانورز احمد النداعش يخطط بجديه لاعاده
احياء نفسه ومناطق سيطرته من جديد انطلاقا
من الرقه ومخيم الهول في سوريا
من تصريحات الاضاعه قاموا فيها انه راح
يزيدوا من عملياتهم
وحمله الانتقام بلشوها بالمنطقه
خصوصا بعد هالعمليات اللي تمت بهذا
الاستهدافات اللي تمت
وايضا مخطط الهجوم على المخيم والتحضيرات
الموجوده بالمخيم
نرى انه لازال هدف
بالتوسع هدف بالتنظيم
حتى هن يقولوا اعلان الخلافه مره اخرى لا
زال مستمرين بهالدف من داخل المخيم مخيم
الهول طبعا في داخل المخيم ايضا موجود
يعني موجودين وعم ينشروا تصريحات
معلومات يوجهون للناس الموجودين ضمن
المخيم
احمد قالت في مقابلتها مع العربيه ان داعش
بدا يعتمد بشكل اكبر على النساء في عمليات
الهجوميه واوضحت ان امراه من التنظيم تولت
التنسيق في سجن غويران داخل مخيم الغول
قسم متشردين جدا وخصوصا
بحمله التمشيط الاخيره حتى الهجوم على سجن
صناعه
المعلومات المتواجد لدينا انه الذ
الشخص الذي كان يقوم
يعني الاتصال ما بين السجن وخارج السجن
كانت امراه من ضمن المخيم
وضعت في الفتره الاخيره يعتمد على النساء
اكثر لنلاقي صعبه
بالتحرك الرجال ضمن المنطقه تدابير
الامنيه فيقوم بتنظيم المراه
ويكلفها بعض العمل اكثر من الرجال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في تركيا اعلنت زعيمه حزب الخير المعارض
ضاميرال لاكشنر رفض حزبها ترشيح رئيس حزب
الشعب الجمهوري كمال كلش دار اوغلو في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله وهكذا ان كل
المؤشرات تدفع لضروره ترشيح رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول او رئيس بلديه انقره مشيره الى ان
حزبها لن يرضخ لضغوط مائده الست
من جهته قلل كمال جلتشدار اوغلو زعيم
المعارضه من الخلاف حول المرشحين للرئاسه
ووجه كريستيانو كلامه لانصاره احزاب
المعارضه قائلا لا تقلقوا ستكون الامور
على ما يرام
خمسه وسبعون يوما فقط تفصل الشارع التركيه
على الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه التي
ستجرى مع تاكيد اردوغان على ان الموعد لم
يتغير وسيكون بتاريخ 14 من مايو المقبل
وفق تقرير صادر عن وكاله دبلومبرغ تمر
المعارضه التركيه بازمه خانقه بسبب الفشل
في الاتفاق على مرشح مشترك لمنافسه الرئيس
التركي الذي اتهم الاحزاب المعارضه
بالفوضى والانقسام بشان قضايا تتعلق
باداره البلاد على حسب تعبيره
ليكن هذا واضحا للجميع هذه الامه ستفعل ما
هو ضروري في الرابع عشر من مايو الشعب
التركي سيرد على هؤلاء المغرضين ولن يابه
لمن يرددون الشعارات والمقولات الفارغه
توحيد جبهه المعارضه في هذه الانتخابات
بات ضروريه لكسب المعركه السياسيه وفق
مراقبين وفشلوا الحكومه في التعاطي مع
عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه سيشكل ورقه رابحه
بالنسبه لها حيث ان قاده الطاوله السداسيه
للمعارضه التركيه تقول انها ستعلن خلال
ايام مرشحها المشتركه لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ووسط التكهنات المتداوله اكد
زعيم الحزب الصالح القومي التركيه المعارض
ان الحزب لن يستسلم لمحاولات محاصرته حيث
طرح ترشيح رئيس بلديه انقره من سوريا واش
ورئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو لخوض
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن الاحزاب الخمسه
الاخرى لم تقبل بذلك وقامت بترشيح كمال
كالجدار اوغلو لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
تضارب التصريحات طرح سيناريوهات المتعدده
ابرزها خروج المعارضه باكثر من مرشح بهدف
ارباك ساحه المؤيدين للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وسط تحليلات تشير الى ارتفاع حدود
المعارضه في تحقيق فوز على اردوغان بعد
كارثه الزلزال من جهه او تصويت اقل من نصف
ناخبين لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه ما
سيسمح للرئيس التركي بالتغلب في صناديق
الاقتراع
غصت شوارع زاهدان جنوب شرق ايران
بالمحتجين البروش الذين خرجوا عقب صلاه
الجمعه في مظاهره حاشده ورفع المتظاهرون
الى فتاه تحمل شعار الموت للديكتاتور
وللحرس الثوري
[موسيقى]
انتقد وزير الخارجات الايرانيه حسين امير
عبداللهيان تدخل مسؤولين غربيين في قضيه
حالات تسمم الطالبات في ايران واصفا اياها
باستمرار حرب الاعداء ليكمل بذلك ما بداه
رئيسى باثاره الاضطرابات في بلاده عبر
اشاعه الذعر في نفوس الطلاب واهاليهم
ارض خصبه للابتلاع اعذار النظام الايراني
وامتصاص اخطائه تحولت لها دول الغرب فهناك
يرمي انتهاكاته بمجالاتها المتعدده ليزعم
وقوف من يصفهم بالاعداء خلف كل ما يجري في
بلاده
فصول قمع الاحتجاجات لم تنتهي بعد ليتسرب
عبرها غاز تسبب بتسمم طالبات في المدارس
هذه ايضا تهمه الصقها بطريقه ما الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي بالغرب الذي يسعى
وفق تعبيره لاشاعه التوتر والذعر بين
الطلاب واولياء امورهم واثاره الاضطرابات
في ايران
معاناه الفتيات الايرانيات وسلبهن حق
التعليم بات موضع قلق دول غربيه عده بينها
الولايات المتحده والمانيا فهجمات السم
الخفيف فسرها السياسيون على انها استهداف
من قبل الجماعات المتشدده المعارضه لتعليم
الفتيات
يجب ان تتمكن الفتيات من الذهاب الى
المدرسه بلا خوف هذا حقهن الانساني ببساطه
يجب التحقيق بشكل كامل في كل الحالات
حالات تسمم متوسطه لمئات الفتيات اعلنت
عنها وزاره الصحه الايرانيه خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه وبين السوق الاتهامات
والقاء اللوم وجه رئيس وزير الداخليه
والامن بمتابعه قضايا التسمم في المدارس
فيما كلف رئيس مجلس الشورى محمد باقر
قليباث اربعه لجان برلمانيه بالتحقيق
واكتشاف اسباب الحوادث وقد تم القاء القبض
على ثلاثه اشخاص اشتبه بتورطهم في القضيه
لكن الاجهزه الامنيه نفت اكتشافها لماده
سامه قد تكون السبب في تسمم الطلبه
ايراني اخر وصل المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه رافايل جروسي الى
طهران لاجراء مناقشات بشان برنامج ايران
النووي وذلك بعد اكتشاف جزيئات من
اليورانيوم المخصب بمستوى قريب من صنع
قنبله ذريه ومن المقرر ان يلتقي جروسي
خلال الزياره بمدير منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه محمد اسلامي ومسؤولين اخرين بمن
فيهم الرئيس ابراهيم رئيس
يه السعوديه عن استنكار المملكه الشديد
للتصريحات المتطرفه التي ادلى بها احد
مسؤولي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال
مطالبته بمحو قريه حوار الفلسطينيه واكدت
الخارجيه السعوديه رفض المملكه التام لهذه
التصريحات العنصريه مشدده على مطالبتها
للمجتمع الدولي بالاطلاع بمسؤولياته لردع
هذه الممارسات المشينه ووقف التصعيد
وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين
وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي دعى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الى التبرع من تصريحات وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي واكد ان الاتحاد واكد
الاتحاد ان تصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي غير
مقبوله ولا يمكن التسامح معها مجددا تمسكه
بمبادئ شرعيه الدوليه لحل النزاع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
لندن على اجراء تحقيق في مقتل فتى فلسطيني
قرب قلقيليه في الضفه الغربيه الخبيث
وعبرت القنصليه البريطانيه في القدس في
حسابها على تويتر عناصر فيها بسبب عدم
استقرار المستمر والخسائر في الارواح في
جميع انحاء الضفه الغربيه كما قررت دعوتها
الى ضبط النفس عند استخدام الجيش
الاسرائيلي لبخيره الحيه
بعد مرور اكثر من يومين منذ وقوع حادثه
تصادم قطارين في مدينه لاريسا في وسط
اليونان يواصل عمال الانقاذ عمليات البحث
وازاله الحطام في موقع الحادث التي اوقعت
اكثر من سته او 57 قتيله
[موسيقى]